yeah joining us now altered best-selling
book Trump's America the truth about our
nation's great comeback former Speaker
of the House Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich isn't that nice ten days in it
get a nice free vacation it pay for a
private jet I didn't know they pay for
the private jet and the meals and the
hotel and they get to put suntan lotion
on each other it's really nice bonding
you know they've they've developed very
intricate rules that allow them to do
pretty much what they want to while
still claiming they're following the
rules but I think the picture neither
saw Lilia also shows you the roadmap for
the president I mean the president's
position ought to be then we're not
going to kick the can any further down
the road we're going to get it solved
now and that he ought to call the
Congress in and keep their feet to the
fire and say look you guys have an
obligation to stay here and to focus on
this somebody suggested the radical idea
that maybe the Congress should not be
paid during the shutdown so that they
went through the same process as the
federal civil servants who are not going
to get paid and maybe that would focus
their attention but I think the
president ought to come back again and
again and say look this is your job you
the Congress are supposed to be solving
it and you should stay here till you get
it solved I think that's a strongest
position let me let me ask you this
because I understand the concern there
were times in my life
long period of my life my early adult
life I live paycheck to paycheck I have
great sympathy for the furloughed
employees I'm told the source telling me
that there are there is a group of
Democrats and there is a group of
Republicans that might appeal to the
President to give them a certain period
of time to solve the problem and if they
don't get it done he would declare a
national emergency would you support
that no I really think they should focus
on the Congress doing its job I mean
that the president declaring a national
emergency is sidestepping the central
problem which we're going to have for
the next few years
with speaker Pelosi you have a hard-line
left wing Democratic
party whose radical wing now is well to
the left of Bernie Sanders they have no
interest in governing they have no
interest in working with the President
on States and frankly what he ought to
do is go back and look at the Reagan
playbook when I was a junior congressman
we never got Tip O'Neill support what we
got was a large block about a third of
the Democrats who decided they'd vote
with us and between the Republicans and
that one-third we passed things like the
three-year tax cut now if you thought of
Kevin McCarthy as a potential leader of
a coalition 46 Democratic freshmen wrote
a note like that and said to Speaker
Pelosi they want to legislate well let's
give them a chance to legislate but I
think that the Reagan model which is to
go to the country to find individual
Democrats the leadership is never going
to cut a deal they killed one so the
shutdown aspect of it indefinite
well--that's indefinite but I would I
would an urge frankly the leader
McCarthy to put together a discharge
petition in the house and get every
single Republican to sign it that says
look we're going to fund the southern
border and we're going to fund the
government and we're ready to vote to do
both and then start looking at the
number of Democrats in the last four
days who have come out individually and
said you know I could vote for the
southern border I could vote for the
wall there there's a growing number
under the pressure of this whole thing
who's trying to say well look I don't
want to be unreasonable but that's going
to come at the bottom it's not going to
come at the top and they ought to start
looking at what's the procedure to find
40 or 50 Democrats combine them with the
Republicans and get things passed on a
bipartisan basis in effect beating
Pelosi and the left wing of the
Democratic Party all right
it raises a lot of questions I don't
disagree with your strategy I don't care
which way the president gets the money
personally if he does the national
emergency stays with the shutdown forces
the Democrats at some point
to step up and do their job we do need
to control the border the drugs the
human trafficking etc mr. speaker good
to see you happy New Year and we
appreciate you being with us